well brian nevada assembly speaker jason  fryerson says he wants to spread  awareness about prostate cancer after  his own diagnosis  fryerson had surgery last week in order  to treat it and he returned to the  legislature today  he says that fortunately it was caught  early and he is recovering  he introduced a bill today that would  make september ovarian and prostate  cancer awareness month  for something as simple as having your  prostate checked  it's a it's just a no-brainer and it's  such a non-aggressive typically  non-aggressive form of cancer  that it's so treatable if you're willing  to talk about it so  you know you know these are not the  kinds of things that people  uh you know are comfortable talking  about so let's normalize it  fryerson had to go to california for his  treatment which is a newer technique  he's using a cryotherapy treatment that  freezes the tumor